laurie avec nous pour en parler
pierre tattevin infectiologues chef du
service des maladies infectieuses du chu
de rennes
philippe froguel chercheur généticien
vous est également professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et de
l'université lille 2 et enfin lexsi
poulain notre éditorialiste bonsoir à
tous les trois messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur l'antenne d'arte
et france sont en train de retrouver un
mot n'a peut-être au milieu de ce duplex
ça qu'on n'a pas réussi à joindre tout à
l'heure pour nous faire un état des
lieux de cette pression qu'eux mais le
gouvernement sur les français pour
qu'ils aillent se faire vacciner dans le
spectre un évidemment d'une quatrième
vague alors chaque jour cette pression
son sexe ans tué d'un cran le
gouvernement a clairement un discours
alarmiste alors que l'on vient tout
juste de lever les dernières
restrictions la situation est-elle
vraiment préoccupante pierre tattevin
un clarté de 20 décidément alors on va
on va se tourner vers un philippe
froguel en espérant que lui nous entende
philippe froguel décidément c'est une
farce ce soir voilà merci on vous entend
bon philippe froguel je vais me tourner
vers vous allez nous sauver je crois ne
se veut de ce mauvais pas où je vais
finir par faire mon nom c'est d'être
numéro de claquettes à l'antenne ça fait
tellement d'années je veux le faire ça
va être pour ce soir je pense en cette
fin d'année
est ce que c'est une situation aussi
alarmante
philippe froguel pour l'instant avait
pas alarmante en france même si l
augmentation en nombre de corps mais
j'ai vu tout à l'heure ce qui se passait
aux pays bas avec une augmentation de
500% du nombre des personnes a contaminé
en une semaine et si c'est la même chose
qui nous arrive en france dans quelques
semaines en risque est d'athènes la
situation avec plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de cas par par jour à et on
espère que ça sera surtout des jeunes
qui n'ont pas besoin d'être hospitalisée
mais hélas comme l'a dit le gouvernement
il ya encore 20 % des plus de 80 ans qui
sont pas vaccinés et une bonne partie
des plus de 50 ans en plus on a vu dans
et cher aujourd'hui que une dose ne
suffisait pas et qu' il fallait
absolument avoir deux doses pour être
protégés contre le variant delta donc il
ya de quoi être pas paniquer comme alors
d'être le gouvernement mais d'être
inquiet et de tout faire mais vraiment
tout faire pour ralentir au maximum la
population de cette nouvelle épidémie
pierre tattevin je me retourne vers vous
un discours donc alarmistes du du
gouvernement
alors que les discothèques par exemple
sont supposés ouvrir demain par mona on
a perdu définitivement pierre tattevin a
enfin écoutez olivier verront ils
débrayaient latin qui était au centre de
vaccination de notre long terre pour une
petite séance de pédagogie avant de vous
faire réagir alexis poulin et côté le
ministre de la santé surtout mon message
était de leur dire que le vaccin il les
protège à 95% des formes graves
par contre les protège à 100% du
confinement c'est dire que si tout le
monde est vaccinée on n'aura plus à se
poser la question de savoir si nos
restaurants nos bars à nos commerces et
des universités peuvent rester ouverte
dans la durée on n'aura plus à se poser
la question de savoir si on doit ou non
porter le masque à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur on en aura fini avec le
virus ou retrouvera nos vie d'avant
alexis couleur clairement les les
ministres en service commandé en faveur
de la vaccination il faut dire que le
risque est gros et le risque politique
pour emmanuel macron sûr sur cette
séquence
oui évidemment et même à compenser
qu'avec la campagne de vaccination
s'accélérant et atteignant sa vitesse de
croisière
le virus était derrière nous et puis
arrive le variant les variants delta
epsilon et puis je ne sais pas quelle
lettre grecque va arriver après et on se
rend compte que l'efficacité du vaccin
certes là mais moindres est que il ya
une course de vitesse qui est finalement
engagée alors même qu'on ne sait pas si
ça va fonctionner sur un prochain
mariage donc la promesse qui était celle
finalement dû déconfinement de la
liberté retrouvée avec d'un côté la
vaccination de l'autre on garde tout de
même les gestes barrière est en train de
s'éloigner un peu partout y compris en
france
on est en train nous en france d'ouvrir
les discothèques alors que les chiffres
arrivent en disant qu'il ya eu 200
contamination le week-end dernier deux
dans un pays européen qui avait ouvert
cette discothèque est donc la question
est qui veut ouvrir qui le fermer et
puis on a la grande bretagne à côté de
nous un pays largement vaccinés ou le
delta a pris le dessus et où boris
johnson fait finalement et bien ça
suffit on va arrêter d'enfermer les gens
on va arrêter avec tout ça même les
masses car ce sera à la discrétion de
chacun il faut que la vie reprenne avec
ce livre ça alors c'est pas paris à
prendre est ce que la vie peut continuer
avec ce virus
ou est ce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire qui attend l'angleterre là
c'est un choix qui est critiqué par
certains scientifiques
du côté britannique mais c'est un choix
qui est fait et puis en inde on a vu
aussi que le delta est passée par là et
puis les contaminations ont décru donc
on n'arrive pas à comprendre comment
fonctionne finalement ce coronavirus on
pense que la vaccination est l'alpha et
l'oméga sans jeu de mots de la solution
mais la solution ne restent pas que ça
il ya aussi les gestes barrières les
masquer le fait aussi d'être vigilants
par rapport à ça et de voir comment
fonctionne ce bien aujourd'hui on ne
sait toujours pas on al impression qu on
tâtonne malgré cette vaccination alors
maintenant jean castex nous dit que
c'est de non pas une ni deux mais trois
doses pour que ça fonctionne
est ce que ce sera après une dose par
trimestre une dose par an tout ça est
vraiment finalement ça n'aide pas parce
que aujourd'hui que veulent les
gouvernants c'est que le monde reparte
l'économie reparte surtout parce que
toutes les prédictions qui sont dans les
tuyaux les 5% de croissance de bruno le
maire si jamais l'épidémie est arrivé et
qu'il fallait reconfirmer ou retrouver
des mesures coercitives
alors là patatras ça ne marchera pas et
puis d'un autre côté vous avez des
populations qui en ont ras-le-bol et qui
ne veulent plus de mesures liberticides
qui veulent retrouver leur liberté
quoi qu'il en coûte puisqu'on nous parle
de quoi qu'il en coûte systématiquement
et un moment on commence à se dire mais
quand est ce qu'on va voir la fin de ce
virus
on a l'impression que c'est une histoire
sans fin philippe froguel clairement à
ce qu'on allait les moyens de cette
liberté aujourd'hui alexis poulain
faisait référence au royaume uni on a vu
ces images ça ne nous a pas échappé aux
humbles et fière de ses supporters
britanniques aiment à sceller les uns
sur les autres on en pense qu'on veut
mais c'est vrai qu'on en plein qu'ovide
ça peut faire bizarre dans le même temps
il ya ce test concert se concertaient ça
paris 1 avec masques alors c'était le 29
mai avant le delta où la conclusion
c'est pas de sur risque de contamination
clairement aujourd'hui on peut se
permettre encore ces attroupements cette
réouverture des des discothèques
en réalité la science ne peux rien vous
dire aujourd'hui puisque tout est un
prêt était imprévisible
sauf que le delta les tenir moi je fais
partie de ceux qui début juin on dit à
olivier ferrand attention aura lancé la
vaccination parce que
début juillet s'avéraient augmenté et je
garantis que le gouvernement et pas sur
cette ligne il était sur une ligne tout
va bien et il faut construire et forêts
pour les élections maintenant c'est tout
va mal et donc personne ne sait si on
sera sur la pente des pays bas ou sur la
pente anglaise et la la qu'est-ce qui
fera la très très grande différence
peut-être c'est les personnes de 2 puis
de 50 ans parce que le confinement n'est
pas fait il n'a jamais été fait en
france une seule raison qui est de
éviter l'engorgement des hôpitaux donc
temps que les hôpitaux sont pas engorger
je ne pense pas qu ils raison autre
nouvelle de faire le confinement
maintenant de faire que les choses
soient respectées dans les restaurants
j'ai encore vu à midi à lille s'était
pas respecté le fait que c'est peut-être
pas la meilleure chose à faire demander
d'ouvrir libre des boîtes de nuit
aujourd'hui ça c'est sûr mais surtout
surtout surtout il faut que les gens se
vacciner comprennent qu'il faut trois
semaines pour qu'un vaccin soit efficace
et moi j'ai entendu sur des radios
aujourd'hui des télés et des gens qui
disaient ah mais je me faire vacciner
pour partir en vacances à barcelone où
je vais faire la fête
non hélas je suis vraiment désolé le
dire il faut trois semaines est en
réalité il faut deux doses de vaccin
pour que ce soit efficace
on a un mois de retard sur le variant
delta par rapport aux anglais les la
somme à deux mois de retard sur la
vaccination ne sait simplement qu'elle
inquiète en tout cas gabriel apte à lui
clairement fait planer la menace ans
restriction à nouveau je vous propose de
l'écouter
si on veut ne pas avoir à reprendre des
restrictions des mesures hyper
contraignantes
il faut qu'on atteigne l'immunité
collective et donc se vacciner c'est un
petit pas pour soi mais c'est un grand
pas pour l'immunité
tiens ta devant vous a retrouvé avec
bonheur quand vous voyez cette pression
monte un le gouvernement qui souffle le
chaud et le froid qui dit que l'était
peut être gâché dans le même temps ceux
des confine totalement ça vous inspire
quoi vous en tant qu' en tant que
médecin il est désolé pour les soucis
connexion j'ai entendu tout n'est j'ai
entendu ce que disait qu'il progrès j'ai
tout à fait d'accord un effectivement on
a notre chance de ne pas subir une trop
grosse vague à la rentrée ça va être
d'être le mieux vacciner possible et de
ne pas faire de folies pendant cet été
et donc je pense qu'on a du répit de on
espère quelques semaines c'est le moment
pour améliorer des couvertures
vaccinales et éviter une pire on vient
entendre avec six poulains gabriela
talent clairement il ya ça défaut de
rendre la vaccination obligatoire il ya
cette petite musique qui ressemblerait à
un gentil chantage
en gros c'est soit on vous re confie non
on vous prive de votre liberté ou soit
vous allez passer à la piqûre
complètement
c'est vraiment là la politique du nudge
à celle qui pousse les gens à faire
quelque chose sans les obliger à mais en
rendant tout contraignant
ce passeport vaccinale c'est pas
sanitaire inquiets certains voudraient
obligatoire même pour aller au
restaurant ou n'importe où dans les
lieux de la vie publique et puis le fait
de dire qu'il y aura finalement pour les
non vaccinés plein de barrières pour
plein de choses
la question de la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants bien sûr qui
est sur la table tout ça qui pose
question parce qu'on attende de savoir
si effectivement les vaccins vont
fonctionner avec les nouveaux variants
on voit bien alors certes il fonctionne
sur les cas graves sur l'hospitalisation
visiblement il ya une décorrélation
entre les cas de contamination et les
gens qui se retrouvent à l'hôpital donc
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle mais qu'en
sera-t-il de la suite et combien de
piqûres vont être nécessaires pour
l'immunité
donc aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya
une poussée aussi du gouvernement avec
attal avec cette poussée sur les jeunes
de vouloir vacciner
jeunes de 12 à 18 ans en disant c'est
eux qui doivent se faire vacciner parce
qu' ils ont peut-être bien sûr la
rentrée scolaire en septembre si cette
rentrée n'est pas préparés alors nous
aurons des supercluster et des nouveaux
événements contaminants dans les écoles
c'est exactement les erreurs qui ont été
faites en 2020 même si elles n'ont pas
été qualifiées d' erreur à l'époque un
corps de monsieur castex avant d'être
premier ministre était monsieur
déconfinement et bien les cabinets de
conseil qui l'entouraient avait dix mois
les i c'est bon on peut tout à fait vrai
les écoles aujourd'hui on voit bien que
la préparation est en amont et qu'il ya
évidemment le temps de la vaccination
ce temps là c'est un décalage
effectivement entre première deuxième
dose et efficacité c'est à moi qu'il
faut compter
le mois d'août est aujourd'hui donc on
pousse la population française à se
vacciner pour s'assurer évidemment une
couverture à partir de septembre sans
être sûr qu'un nouveau variant ne
pourrait pas arriver et rebattre les
cartes puisque c'est le cas pour des
pays qui se pensait à l'abri qui avait
mis le virus derrière eux eh bien non
c'est plus compliqué que ça avec 7
cette façon de faire du coronavirus qui
reste encore à voir est effectivement
aujourd'hui la clé c'est le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation
qu'ovide dans les hôpitaux
si il reste en deçà de ce qu'on a connu
alors il n'y a pas de raison de confiner
ou de continuer avec des mesures
liberticides
avec le danger bien sûr de ces mesures
contraignantes de diviser la population
française de faire une une population
vip qui seraient les vacciner et plus
une population de renégats qui seraient
les non vaccinés qui auraient droit à
rien ça c'est dangereux je crois qu'il
ya une rupture du compte du pacte
républicain dans cette pente glissante
qui est en train d'être martelé
systématiquement pour inciter les gens à
vacciner
philippe rogué d'une question peut-être
naïve mais à partir du moment où les
plus fragiles sont vaccinés
et les populations qui ne sont pas à
risque ne le sont pas pourquoi ne pas
laisser faire tout simplement et créer
ainsi une unité collective alors ça ça a
été essayé de certaines façons la
dernière notamment en septembre et on a
bien vu ce qui s'était passé
c'est à dire que progressivement les
jeunes se sont contaminées et ont fini
par contaminer leurs parents leurs
grands parents les soins des personnes
plus âgées
vous me direz la plupart donnez moi
c'est la différence est qu'aujourd'hui
ces personnes allaient les plus âgés
seront vaccinés oui mais il ya toujours
un hic et l'oeil ya deux types
d'ailleurs le premier c'est qu'il ya
encore 20 % des plus de 80 ans qui sont
pas vaccinés et une forte proportion des
mots des plus de 50 ans et deuxièmement
à partir de 80 ans il ya un papier qui
est sorti la semaine dernière qui disait
je pense que ces colis aussi pour la
grippe et d'autres vaccinations que la
vaccination a marché certaines personnes
âgées mois chez d'autres et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faudrait que les soignants
notamment des ehpad soit vaccinée pour
éviter de ramener le virus à des gens
qui sont peut-être pas très très bien
protégé dans les ehpad clairement pierre
tattevin que peu annonce emmanuel macron
début de semaine en tout cas vous en
tant que médecin qu'est ce que vous
espérez de la part du président de la
république aujourd'hui je crois que
l'obligation vaccinale pour personnel de
100 kg et tous les gens qui sont au
contact de personnes à un risque est
vraiment importante j'entendais ce que
disait votre éditorialistes il ya deux
choses à mon avis qu'il faut revoir un
peu c'est d'abord on sait qu'il marche
ces vaccins c'est à dire que même dans
les pays où ces revenus parce que
servent à rien en plus contagieux les
gens vaccinés ont été protégés ce qui
ensuite de doses du vaccin ont fait
beaucoup moins de variants delta que les
autres et puis la deuxième chose on sait
que si on laisse trop circuler le virus
on va avoir de plus en plus de variance
assez brave à être de plus en plus fort
c'est pour ça qu'il faut être très bien
vacciné c'est plus on sera mieux
vacciner à l'échelle d'une population -
y aura-t-il appellation du virus est
moins de chance d'avoir encore à nous
enverrions ypsilon ce que vous voulez
après le delta la protection c'est le
baxo philippe froguel aujourd'hui
l'exécutif qui déconseille aux français
de
de réserver des vacances en espagne au
portugal est ce que c'est c'est justifié
ce type de conseils pas très sympathique
d'ailleurs pour les espagnols et les
portugais qui comptait un petit peu se
refaire avec le tourisme bon d'abord la
situation au portugal et en espagne ça
va être la situation demain dans le sud
de la france où là vous les gens vont
aller en vacances ou loups aux dents
dans les plages de l'atlantique donc on
a simplement quelques semaines d' avance
mais hélas je crains qu'on va avoir la
même situation
bientôt on sait pas très sympathique
c'est clair et c'est un peu
protectionnistes et je pense pas que les
gens qui ont déjà réservé leur relais et
l'hôtel avant ne pas partir à barcelone
ou à au portugal donc ce c'est ce que
j'appellerais une déclaration à
déclaratives verbales mais qui dit il
montre pas grand chose
alexis poulain à dix mois de l'élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron on imagine marche sur
des oeufs
c'est sa candidature qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui oui enfin c'est un des
sujets évidemment si cette crise
sanitaire a n'est pas gérée à la fin de
l'année ça va être très compliqué pour
lui de se représenter d'avoir un bilan à
défendre puisque il pensait en avoir
fini puis il a il a eu quelques
décisions controversées
quand il a choisi de ne pas confiné de
continuer avec plus de cent mille morts
à l'époque il a été vivement critiquée
puis en disant finalement il avait
peut-être pas tort la façon dont il a
géré cette crise aussi de manière
extrêmement personnelle avec ses
conseils de défense qu'il présidait les
conseils de dépenses reviennent avec
bien sûr tout l'opacité qui vont avec le
fait qu'ils décident entouré certes de
conseiller mais c'est lui qui va
cristalliser bien sûr les critiques
puisqu'il a voulu être au premier rang
de cette gestion de la crise sanitaire
alors ils gardent bien sûr olivier
ferrand au ministre de la santé et jean
castex jusqu'à la fin de cette crise
sanitaire parce que ça n'a aucun sens de
s'en séparer en plein en pleine crise
donc on va voir et évidemment ça peut
être compliqué puis il ya le reste les
bilans des réformes qu'il veut remettre
sur la table réforme de
l'assurance-chômage réforme des
retraites qui là aussi sont extrêmement
contestée donc 7
une fin de mandat difficile sachant
qu'en plus en réalité le mandat est déjà
terminé l'action ne peut pas se faire
sur les quelques mois qui reste c'est du
déclaratif également de dire que
l'action durera jusqu'à la dernière
minute c'est pour se mettre en scène et
dire qu'il aura tout fait pour essayer
de faire passer des réformes
s'il se déclare à nouveau candidat pour
sa réélection
ça c'est ce qu'on verra dans la suite
des opérations mais clairement si la
crise sanitaire n'est pas géré je vois
pas comment il pourrait se représenter
devant les français merci en tout cas à
tous les trois alexis pour la pierre
tattevin qu'on est heureux finalement
d'avoir interviewé quelques minutes
philippe froguel également merci à tous
les trois